on les aperçoit dans les faons du
trottoir ou dans notre jardin on les
appelle les nuisibles comestibles
on est en mauricie à
saint-mathieu-du-parc on est à l'auberge
saint mathieu dulac est l'endroit où je
suis chef
sur les rives du lac bellemare s'est mis
belabed admire le décor qui inspirent sa
cuisine ils cultivent un potager mais se
laisse aller à cueillir des plantes qui
ont moins bonne réputation
canton un potager où toute une
exploitation maraîchère cet exploit des
légumes qu'exploite du plant sem puis
tout ce qui est autour qui poussent de
manière sporadique on les enlève parce
que on veut concentrer l'énergie du sol
les nutriments du sol à l'aplomb sans
même se demander qu'est ce qui enlève
pas automatiquement et enlève les
mauvaises herbes manière spontanée avec
un peu de recherche puis en s'y penchant
on réalise que c'est des plantes à part
entière qui ont des propriétés parfois
parfois médicinales ou d'autres fois des
propriétés gustatives qui sont
intéressantes
[Musique]
20 justement là ici du plantain ah c'est
ça moi ça pousse partout si même les
trottoirs on la reconnaît justement pas
le petit berger
donc finalement ça pousse bien d'un
stationnement si je comprends qu ali
salem les sols comme un i married les
sols secs les seuls rocailleux ces
nuisibles comestibles que j'utilise je
vais pas l'écrire dans le stationnement
ou ou en bord de route faut qu'on peut
les identifier dans notre quotidien on
peut les retrouver dans un milieu qui
est un peu plus naturelle ou dans nos
potagers qui beaucoup plus contrôlés
d'un point de vue sanitaire
afin de vous aider à bien identifier des
herbes nuisibles comestibles dans votre
cour vos plates-bandes ou vos potagers
il existe deux nouveaux ouvrages fort
intéressant donc cantine sauvage de
nathalie le coz et martin perron ainsi
que cueillir la forêt d'ariane paris le
gall et gérald le gal une de mes
préférées selamat ricardo d'europe qui
est dans la même famille que la
camomille c'est le goût de la nana
notamment anglais on l'appelle pana
paulo id pour pour ce pour ce fils puis
elle est partout soit dans nos potagers
à l'appareil mais aussi elle aime les
endroits reid fait parfois en pleine
ville on la trouve en qh les cracks de
trottoir quand qu'on s'y attarde on
réalise que si c'est la matca odorantes
entre les étals de béton on a de
l'oxalys dressé
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est ça goûte la
rue bab acide très acidulé en salade
c'est le fun ça fait saliver avec 10
points chez les ch'ti tcp remplacer
le citron facilement garder aussi tout
ce qui est encerclée du trèfle qui vaut
au printemps va donner des petits pots
mauvais qu'on peut utiliser ces fleurs
là aussi en salade ou sécher après en
tisane c'est ici c'est ce qu'indique et
n'a pas de blancs donc j'ai fait une
petite
petite culture sélective j'ai laissé se
pousser j'attends l'automne lorsque les
gars n 10 qui n'a pas de vent vont être
à maturité pour
faire de la farine de graines de quinoa
pas de blancs très très haute teneur en
protéines
l'amarante escardines oui juste ici on
voit là des litiges dans ma route qui
fait justement ces graines comme le
chénopode qu'on va récolter
à la fin de l'automne
900 lits évidemment
on connaît assez bien et le lierre
terrestre juste à côté et je prends le
lierre qui que des fleurs donc le lierre
qui fait des petits boulots théorie
l'exacte les petites fleurs mauves brut
et c ur que je récolte parce que c'est
le lierre de la première année donc de
la première pouces et plus d'engendrer
beaucoup plus parfumé plus chargées en
huiles essentielles en cuisine
maintenant c'est me prépare un pesto aux
herbes nuisibles excellent sur di paolo
du pourpier du chénopode de l'amarante
cdm qui sont bien verte on aurait pu
rajouter du plantain puissant lui aussi
je vais tout en m à quantité près 50 50
des épinards pour
la texture qui pour la couleur sur tous
les tenants beaucoup de chlorophylle
une fois blanchi les herbes sont passés
au robot avec de lag et de l'huile un
buste haut revient à laissons nos potes
ils craignent aussi une salade avec une
touche de son pesto une émulsion de
verveine et de basilic citron sur une
suite gélifiée d'eau de thomas du buzz
laisseront à la coriandre et au basilic
de son jardin s'ajoutent l'oxalys de
pourprix verte ainsi que la milice
cueilli quelques minutes auparavant dans
la cour de l'auberge aller cueillir sa
chair pour vous
merveilleux
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir un bouquet
qui percute en huiles essentielles avec
toutes les les la famille d'herbe qu'on
a ici le
qu'ils essaient d'aider goûter aussi de
manière individuelle chaque bouchée va
être différente de l'autre
[Musique]
un automate parfumer avec les herbes
direct en effet wang ou de saint mathieu
c'est une richesse c'est vraiment des
trésors qui sont qui sont à notre portée
qu'on peut qu'on peut exploiter plus
qu'on peut apprendre à aimer et surtout
oui puis à faire découvrir aux gens
[Musique]